you've told us a little bit about how we
got to the trying breast milk
conversation but I need a play-by-play
it's how we got there and then also why
you decided to tweet about it
so 85 of new dads at least wonder what
breast milk tastes like we had family
over that day when they asked me they're
like did you try have you tried I'm like
no I haven't tried it but if I ever do
you know I want the whole the whole
shura I want to be burped I want to be
cradled I want I want I want everything
somehow I got finesse into doing like a
blind tasting so we had like almond milk
a creamer and breast milk tried it
obviously and it was vanilla flavored
almond milk that's how it tasted I
literally took the blindfold off after I
tasted I'm like damn is actually like
it's not bad it doesn't taste bad I was
like this gotta be the breast milk and
like I just knew because like it tasted
the best out of all of them so then I
would decide you know I'm just I'm gonna
tweet it and just see what people think